our next script is titled mother written
by Sean Malcolm it's about a Syrian
mother trapped in Aleppo who becomes a
sniper to defend her family in this
scene Farida and her son Sami are
trapped in their rebel-held neighborhood
in Aleppo surrounded by regime forces on
all sides her husband and father have
disappeared after venturing out to find
medicine and the situation has never
been more dire when a charming rebel
commander offers her food in exchange
for a home-cooked meal she has no choice
but to obliged interior Frida's
apartment dining area later that night
the power is still out the dining table
is lit by two candles and a flashlight
Farida sits with sami next to her the
soldier across from them they're
enjoying minced lamb with bread and
chickpeas all three eat with gusto
sami is shy not looking up much but
enjoying the food
my husband says not to eat near the
window when the power is out we've
established solid perimeter around the
area it's safe he chews heartily then
washes it down with water between the
snipers like myself and our anti-tank
missiles every time they try and enter
we stop them she listens eating modestly
rarely looking up sami looks up for a
moment stares at him are they going to
blow up our house soldier studies him
for a long moment no the regime can't
afford to waste munitions on empty
buildings so they wait on the outskirts
avoiding losses they believe if they can
circle us and wait
we'll give up but we'll never surrender
Aleppo right Sami nods as if he
understands looks back to his plate
soldier takes another bite savoring it
we have reinforcements coming armed with
more gifts from the
Americans if we can hold out
there's talk of a negotiation in Geneva
maybe even a ceasefire those words send
a glimmer of hope across the table she
looks at Sammie notices him rubbing his
eye excuse me my son is very tired she
rises picks up one of the flashlights
I'm not tired mama she takes him by the
arm I know I know
say good night to mr. Hameed and thank
you for dinner thank you for dinner mr.
Hamid soldier smiles at him good night
little soldier she guides Sammy away by
the beam of the light interior Sammy's
room continuous she tucks him under his
blanket and hands him the flashlight
don't waste the battery okay okay will
you feed the kitty
yeah I'll feed kidding okay I miss Bubba
me too my love every time I pray I ask
Allah to bring him home me too okay
Allah is watching over us
remember that good night good night mama
she turns off his flashlight leaves his
door slightly ajar interior Freitas
apartment dining area continuous Frieda
sits back at the table across from
soldier I can tell you're a caring
mother thank you
loving your child isn't hard it's
natural yes instinct she sips her water
then looks over at the sniper rifle
leaning against the wall I could never
do what you do he thinks for a moment no
one was born a killer we only fight
because we have to he stares at her
maybe we're not so different
you know you and I she looks at him not
sure she agrees but unwilling to
challenge him I don't know rather it's
instinct or destiny but I know it's his
will it seems to me our instincts often
go against his will but how could I know
for sure he shrugs here's what I can
tell you when it's your life or theirs
the act is simple you raised the barrel
resting it on your arm listening or the
window sill just like this focus the
scope finding your target in the
crosshairs and you hold the butt tight
but guess your cheek to move with the
recoil exhale deeply so your breathing
doesn't move the barrel and when all
your breath has left your body and not
one ounce remains pull the trigger
physics does the rest she looks at him
his eyes only seem colder in the dim
light he puts his arms down something
changes in you you know it can never be
undone when you accept this it becomes
easier she looks at him suddenly aware
of how uncomfortable she's become with a
stranger in her house at this hour well
I hope you enjoyed the meal we
appreciate your kindness he leans back
studying her she's not a problem I can
protect you and your son she looks at
him a bit sideways we're fine
thank you my husband and my father no
any more
to say I'm sorry I didn't want you to
say it in front of your son but you
realized you will never see them again
right she stares at him hard
gaze narrowing he's a survivor and he'll
be home anytime I know and he's very
resourceful he bores back into her with
his eyes you're lying to yourself we're
surrounded the regime would never let
him pass through
he's been disappeared he's been
disappeared if he's not already dead she
stands I want you to leave now
please he looks at her a dark glint in
his eyes he reaches into his pocket
pulls out a nine-millimeter pistol and
casually rests it on the table keeping
it tight in his hand don't make this
difficult you knew I wanted more than a
meal and you let me in no one has to
know
he stands the gun in his hand moves
closer she's shaking a pious woman like
you could could be stoned to death a
pious woman like you could be stoned to
death do the right thing for your son
keep your mouth shut he rushes forward
smothering her with one hand as he puts
the gun to her head with the other
[Applause]